hey guys I'm Kyle voor Bock and Star
Wars is released what is probably its
final trailer for a rogue one a Star
Wars story there's a lot to talk about
here's some stuff that proved our past
theories correct and details about new
characters and which of them might die
so let's breakdown all of these missable
details and make some final predictions
here we go
[Music]
Jim whatever I do I do it to protect you
see understand I understand
we start off with this flashback of
chronic and the death troopers finding
gallon or so we see this shot of gin
hiding in the reeds which kind of
implies gallon made her escape so
chronic couldn't use her as leverage to
make him work for them this also kind of
confirms our theory that gal and her so
is kind of an Oppenheimer figure which
means he's taken by Orson chronic to
build the Death Star but he later
regrets creating essentially a weapon of
mass destruction like the nuclear
warheads Oppenheimer created his desire
to protect gin here shows that Galan
looks like he's actually a good guy
which explains him leaking the death
star info to the rebels my prediction is
that you know the exhaust pipe on the
Death Star that is incomprehensible
stupid to have there and they use it to
blow it up in a new hope well what if
Gowen was the one who put it there and
then he gave the plans to the rebels
like hey let's blow this thing up so the
long running joke about the Death Star's
vulnerability may finally be justified
here another important thing to note
here is the new music that we're hearing
in this trailer now since the last
trailer came out I believe Michael
Giacchino had to replace Alexander des
flat as the composer on the movie so
here we're hearing the force theme but
it's being played with vocals perhaps
like a young girl's voice which kind of
reflects jyn erso is a young girl in
this flashback now check out the scenery
here this really looks like an alien
landscape this location is actually in
Iceland it's at this Beach by the
mountains of this sand this east of the
village of Vik VI K I could say that one
now let's zoom in on critic here look at
this Imperial insignia he just has the
six red squares which means general now
because this is a flashback later on in
the trailer we see him with six red and
six blue which means Admiral but let's
move on
[Music]
so here we see gin waking up violently
from this nightmarish memory the editing
makes it look like she's having this
memory and imperial custody right before
she's broken out by the rebels and
assigned to the mission but judging by
the shakiness of the shot and the
lighting coming from behind as opposed
to from the front in the next jail cell
shot this means that this scene takes
place later on like in the later scene
on the cruiser when she looks out the
window being transported by the rebels
therefore rope one probably won't begin
with a flashback this flashback will
happen later in the first act after she
joins up with the rebels so why is Ginn
in imperial jail most likely for the
list of crimes we heard in the first
teaser forgery of Imperial documents
possession of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest we
see her cellmate here who's kind of like
a weird Cthulhu looking thing or Davy
Jones from the second Pirates movie let
me do an impression gende ha terrible
they look like they're being transported
together later on so maybe they got into
some sort of trouble together who knows
so if you look in the background behind
the stormtrooper outside the cell there
is several floors of cells so this looks
like it's just a massive prison facility
and the rebels broke in here to get Ginn
out so that seems like Jin is really
important to the rebel cause next we see
the occupation of Jedi we see this
interesting looking shiny droid and the
bottom left of the frame and the frame
leads your eye to the cool-looking
looming Star Destroyer overhead but if
you look closely on the bottom right
before the camera moves up there's an
80s T which we see later on in the
trailer this is cool because one of
rogue ones challenges is to feel and
look like a Star Wars movie and with all
new characters and no lightsabers our
Jedi this is kind of a really tough
thing to do
so this trailer really tried to include
more Star Wars iconography like the 80s
T you know the Star Destroyers the
x-wings and weird problems with your dad
I should be in Star Wars after this we
see Jin freed but not from the same
prison cell we saw before this is not an
imperial cargo ship rebels have hijacked
it maybe during transport or during a
stop somewhere we hear casseon and/or
say his voice is muffled under the sound
of ears ringing which is a cool detail
to show this explosion has affected Jin
physically which is another
sample of Gareth Edwards grounding this
movie in the realism of battle we see
the red light go to a green light on the
Imperial cops that Gina's wearing
meaning he's unlocking them but in the
first teaser Gina's back in cuffs being
escorted by the rebels we see her
walking into the hangar my prediction is
that shortly after Kassian takes off
these Imperial cuffs Gina's gonna try to
escape on her own and then Cassie will
have to subdue her and put cuffs back on
I don't think they're gonna trust each
other until later in act 1 so also look
in the background of this handcuff shot
you could see another prisoner in
shackles which kind of looks like the
cellmate from before
mr. Davy Jones cthulhu boy similar hands
and hint of tentacle face up on top he's
also in the left of the frame as the
door explodes
fingers crossed he's our new Jar Jar
Binks character anyways moving on our
rebellion is all that remains to push
back the Empire
I think you might be able to help us
when was the last time you were in
contact with your father
what is this here we see this super
interesting shot of the Ewing flying
over the jet ah rock formation which is
a massive sculpture of a Jedi
this shot may actually come right before
that wide shot of the Ewing flying past
the plateau in the last trailer but this
statue thing is really peaking my
interest here it's kind of similar to
the statues outside the Jedi Temple on
Coruscant rest in peace but look at this
statue here honestly it's in ruins now
like it once stood tall in front of the
plateau protecting it and you see the
lightsaber blade is broken as we all
know lightsaber blades are generated
from Kyber crystals which is the reason
the Imperials are on this planet because
they're trying to grab the Kyber
crystals for the Death Star so that's
some symbolism right there the crystals
sacred use for the lightsabers is now
over now they're being corrupted for the
new evil purpose of powering the Death
Star super laser anyways let's move on
it appears he is critical to the
development of a super weapon
we now know that this rainy rocky planet
is called yeah do do you know what this
planet is called yeah do okay two things
to point out here one I just realized
I've been calling them gallon air so
this whole time instead of beylin or so
and two we seek ganelin or so on this
planet meaning the battle scenes we've
seen from other trailers in this
location are probably part of a rescue
mission to retrieve Galen we also seek
Renick now has his full Admiral insignia
meaning this takes place years after
that first shot of the two of them
together
chronic probably got its promotion by
using Galen to create the Death Star
like his career has been on the back of
all of gaylen's work and like many
nuclear physicists Galen probably didn't
know how his research was gonna get used
probably why he looks like a little sad
boy in this scene Galen is also wearing
a uniform here as well but he has no
insignia so he works for the empire but
he has no military rank like a scientist
or a slave or something and look at this
look of contempt that chronic is giving
Galen right here damn he is P owed with
an exclamation mark this could be after
he found out that Galen leaked info to
the rebels and he has to come punish and
torture him or something we see another
epic shot of the Death Star and this
planet here maybe scurry which is where
the Death Star is being constructed I
don't think it's Jetta because when we
see the Death Star approach Jedi and the
other trailer it was upside down and
orbiting very quickly and this shot it's
not even moving now I don't think this
is the case but this does kind of look
like the Death Star is being launched
from the planet it's kind of like
popping up out of it almost which
reminds me of how in Halo 3 the halo
rings are launched from the arc which is
an artificial shield world that existed
for the sole purpose of making halos
which is kind of like scurry so this
could be the Death Star of being
launched off the planet's surface into
orbit or it could be behind the planet
and I have no depth perception anyways
moving on when father
we need to find him all right how many
do I need they are requesting a call
sign it son rogue wrote one so Jin now
has her whole crew bode rook Bay's
malthus you're in way and we hear her
say he's my father built this thing we
need to find him
this seems to be taking place after the
Jedi portion in the movie I mean look
how upset Jin is it looks like they just
saw the Jedi plateau get destroyed and
now they're very shaken also notice the
window behind Cassy in here it's
flashing blue light that looks like
hyperspace which we know what they used
to escape Jedi some are saying the
background kind of looks like a ah do
but I think they're all wrong my
prediction is that gin and casseon go to
Jedi to talk to saw Guerrera
about how Jin's father Galen might be
involved with all of this and where he
is then the empire strikes by testing
the super laser on the plateau
everyone barely escapes maybe someone
doesn't then they head to yato to find
Galen I'll come back to who doesn't
escape in a second we see Bay's saying
I'm gonna do a new is he talking about
soldiers willing to go on a suicide
mission with him we also see this
interaction between k2s oh and bode they
are requesting a call sign it's a rogue
road one outside the ship it looks warm
and sunny which kind of looks like scre
Eve I think that k2s oh and bode are
using their imperial credentials to land
on scary if to steal the Death Star's
plans which confirms our past theory
that this is bodis purpose on this
mission also the obligatory saying of
the title of the movie and dialogue you
know like we've been doing in the past
three videos we've made about this but
this is also serving a purpose a lot of
people don't really understand what
rogue one is or means why is it called
that oh it's the name he gives the ship
that brings death to the Empire like the
Enola Gay in World War two by what we
see of bodis look at Jin she inspires
him in the moment to give it that
callsign she's a rogue so that's the
name he comes up with in this moment but
it's also fitting that he's the one to
say it because he's an imperial officer
who has gone rogue so in a way we're all
the rogue one huh
moving on
Tiwa that we are dealing with here
measurable look at this awesome shot of
this super shiny floor reflecting Darth
Vader looking out the window as the
Death Star approaches Jedi Darth Vader's
profile is so iconic that's all you need
that and some you know super powerful
floor wax but it's really cool cuz it's
kind of like the shadow of Vader's
growing over Jetta that looks like it's
in flames
Vader's evil presence overtaking the
wreckage of the ancient Jedi tradition
and here we see critic arguing with
Vader we are dealing with
why is he arguing with Vader I mean this
might be keeping with Vader's general
skepticism of military might like in a
new hope with Vader force choking
Admiral mati when he got too arrogant
about the Death Star superior firepower
like Vader's all about the force you
know not you know military might we also
see Imperial officers gazing upon Jedi
on the Death Star
and if figures walking up to chronic you
could see chronic in the background here
wearing white we actually saw him in
this scene in last trailer but who is
this guy walking up to him other
officers turn around to look at him in
respect or fear kind of like clearing a
path this could be yung Tarkin relieving
chronic of his command summoning them to
Vader also young Tarkin is my rap name
anyways we see the screen showing a
satellite view of Jedi's surface which
kind of looks like a military drone
strike view now what is that shape in
the center there could that be the Jedi
Plateau like that dark inner thing with
the Star Destroyer over it let's move on
Kyah has this kind of power what chance
do we have we have hope rebellions are
built on hope and here's our rebel
meeting this seems to be taking place
kind of towards the midpoint of the
movie maybe after Jetta and or Yahoo or
in the rebels rally and launch an attack
on scurry Bodie rook is standing behind
Jin so this must be a good ways into the
movie now run the table clockwise we got
mon mothma cassidy and and or general
Draven Jan Donna battle Organa senator
Jebel jyn erso another rebel senator and
a black rebel senator so there's
diversity now now we know that this is
Bail Organa because the reverse shot of
this meeting in the celebration footage
shows that the person to the left of Jan
to Donna is Jimmy Smits and we have a
new character who was Senator jebel
played by Jonathan eros you might know
him from playing Anderson on Sherlock
also watching this meeting is biston the
furry guy of firing the mounted gun in
the celebration footage who laughs like
and to white Sheldon Mon Calamari we get
a better look at them on the trading
cards release for this movie they're
from Mon Cala the same planet as Admiral
Ackbar and it's cool the hologram of the
death star looks old-school it's all
shaky and glitchy like the Leia hologram
in a new hope and that's the attention
to detail that is super awesome about
this movie it really shows the rebels
are really operating on scraps here we
see an 8th est attacking militia on
Jetta the effects on it look awesome so
much better than the stop-motion
movement from Return of the Jedi I think
that's a real 80s T now at the beginning
of this shot Jin is the person to the
far left exiting frame and there's this
big furry creature running for cover
with like that big pack on him his name
is more off he's a mercenary who wears a
respirator to help him breathe
he might be aligned with sauger era
which leads me to my question about this
what is going on in this battle could
this be saw Barrera mobilizing his
militia to fight against the Empire
occupation kind of like the French
Resistance and we get this crazy new
look at saw Guerrera this is why he
needs that walking stick his feet are
mechanical and he's like a full-on
breathing suit he must have been
severely injured during his battles with
the Empire also this might be a little
on the nose but Jin says rebellions
built on hope you know like the
rebellion from a new hope because we're
all the rogue one
moving on hold on this moment the force
is strong
make ten menifee like a hundred look at
this awesome wide shot of scurry it's
way more industrialized than previous
footage has shown us the empire is
really built into this jungle with like
a massive structure and several channels
leading to it what is that big structure
like the base of a satellite tower
that's what I'm thinking at least some
people online are also saying it could
be a piece of the Death Star super laser
before I had been put into place
oh no about that the launch pad shown at
the bottom of the frame could be the
same location where we see the Imperial
cruiser explode in past trailers I'm
gonna come back to the ship in a second
because that's kind of an important plot
point here we see gin cassian and k2s Oh
in disguise sneaking onto the Imperial
base this confirms that this is scre Eve
not the Death Star how do we know look
at the hull of the ship as they walk
into this tunnel look at the orangish
panel thing there that's the same ship
that explodes on scurry in the last
trailer still coming back to that so we
may not see Jin and company sneak on to
the Death Star this may just be the
underground base there we see some more
of the ER do battle bays and chariot
watches X wings fly by we got these guys
Adria and Ben thing the dew tubes twins
they're mercenaries from the Empire
occupied world of yar Tonga like more
off they could be working with saw
Guerrero's militia and they have more
breathing devices because everyone in
this militia has asthma or if you want
an actual theory maybe the desert air is
hard to breathe I prefer that they're
like where's my inhaler and again check
out this crash x-wing we pointed this
out in past trailers but I think that
this x-wing was part of a rebel struggle
to stop the Empire from occupying Jedi
which is why we see rebel pilots and
shackles on Jedi and other trailers and
this battle on Yahoo really is bigger
than we thought honestly there now what
you're seeing several y-wings bombing
stuff on these big rock formations I'm
really interested in where that's gonna
go but let's move on
take the next chance
now we're seeing more of this grief
battle we see cheer at firing this
really cool looking weapon look at this
thing it kind of looks like a wookie bow
caster like we saw Chewie used in the
original trilogy and in the force
awakens thing but look at this it's like
the arms extend out which kind of is
like if the bow caster is kind of the
crossbow in the Star Wars universe this
looks like it's the long bow of the Star
Wars universe and it fits because
cheerin is kind of the guy who would use
a longbow and here's an important thing
look at this shot of Bodie in this grief
battle he looks wounded doesn't he if he
is that may give some meaning to this
next shot of him charging into the ship
same one with the orange hijo we talked
about earlier notice that he's holding
something in his hand it looks like a
rope like or cables or something here's
my bold prediction this is where Bodie
rook dies right here in this moment like
this shot is him coming to terms with
his death right before he decides to run
in and blow up this Imperial ship and
we've seen this Imperial ship blow up in
other trailers and the explosion is
massive like there were bombs brought on
board or something but why would Bodie
blow it up and it does he killed himself
doing it maybe it contains Kyber
crystals or secrets of the rebels
location on Yavin 4 there has to be
something really important on that ship
or maybe there's just a ton of
stormtroopers on there and he just wants
to clear a path for the escape for the
rest of the crew with the plans and here
we go look at this I didn't think that
this was gonna even be in this movie but
here is a giant space battle with X
wings my theory is that this is actually
gonna be the opening for the movie maybe
these X wings are flying and they
discover the Death Star as it's under
construction and they're like oh my god
we need to assemble a group of people to
take this thing out an ultimate theory
is that this could be at the end of the
movie during the scree phatal when the
Death Star's plans are transferred from
Jin's party to Leia Organa screw and
look in the background here what are
those other ships back there there's
that rounded ship on the right which
kind of looks like a Mon Calamari
Cruiser this other ship looks like a
hammerhead cruiser that's a ship from
Knights of the Old Republic and a
version appears in Star Wars rebels one
of leia organa spotlights actually
involves those chips but be clear it's
not the ship she appears on at the
beginning of a new hope that's a
Karelian Corvette oh I know my Star Wars
ships we see this explosion on Yahoo
this could be part of the battle with
this coming from a y-wing bombing
rade look closely at the figure
surrounding this explosion stormtroopers
a few death troopers and on the far left
we see chronic in white diving away
which I'm so glad he's wearing white
it's making finding him these trailers
really easy for us but the man standing
directly to the left of the explosion
could be gangland my theory is that
chronic has learned that Galen leaked
info to the rebels came to punish him
and during this the rebels arrived to
attack and free Galen all of this is
happening at once or Galen knew that
credit would come for him and he set up
an explosion to go off below this
platform to blow them all to bits
almost like consider this the day you
almost caught Captain Galen er so moving
on
okay there's so much crazy stuff in this
final section here we see the Jetta
plateau getting absolutely wrecked we
see similar lightening like in the dust
cloud like we mentioned in the last
video now who is this in the foreground
here Jin Bodi a Claire temple cameo this
person has long hair like Jin but in the
last trailer it seemed like their ship
was taking off as the plateau was
crumbling around them maybe this
destruction is heading their way and
they're like oh we gotta get out of here
and they hop on and more importantly
look what's around this person look at
these old ruins these could be ancient
Jedi ruins because as we know Jedi's the
homeworld of the Jedi and they look like
the ruins found on the ancient Sith
homeworld of horeb on like we've seen in
Knights of the Old Republic in some of
the extended universe stories and here
we have the clearest shot of Darth Vader
we've seen yet as he approaches critic
very angrily he looks like he's walking
on an off-ramp from a ship this foggy
smokey effect is cool and again it
starts with Vader's outline so this may
be our first epic glimpse of him in
rogue one what I'm thinking is that
mater has come here to execute
Orson cranek out of anger for him
allowing the Death Star's vulnerability
to leave and this could be possible
considering Orson cranek doesn't appear
at all in the later Star Wars movies
unless he's smoked it but if he did come
here to execute chronic that would place
this shot at the end of the movie
considering past trailers show Orson
chronic walking in the aftermath of the
scree faddle now we have this rainy shot
of Galen on his knees looking up in
defeat at chronic looks like he's in
pain
honestly like chronic just hurt him but
this could be the moments after that
explosion went off earlier and Galen is
disappointed that his plan to take out
himself in chronic didn't work and
here's another really important thing
that we see in this trailer look at saw
here it looks like his home is
collapsing around him my theory is that
saws home is located in the ruins we see
located far away from the plateau so
when the city gets blown up Jin's
watching from there and then she has to
leave saw behind and these are his final
words
and saw freaking dyes here sidenote this
kinda reminds me of
save the cheerleader save the world from
heroes see the cheerleader save the
world save the cheerleader save the
world and we close this out with more of
this grief battle we see the Ewings
attacking the ATAC teased the ATAC t on
the far right has its brown cargo bay
doors open these are meant to carry
large cargo you know like cargo bay
doors
the last guy here is we see bays and
cheer it running from the ATAC t as it
stomps through the jungle around them
feels kind of like Jurassic Park or that
one sequence from Peter Jackson's King
Kong where they're running from the
brontosauruses and that's the end of the
trailer which is probably gonna be the
last trailer we get before rogue Wan
comes out in two months and from what I
can tell this movie's gonna be awesome I
mean the visuals are amazing there's
this high stakes story word anyone could
die I mean none of them are guaranteed
to be in later Star Wars movies and
there's some great action with the Death
Star and these war scenes and hopefully
Darth Vader getting in on that I'm
really looking forward to covering
everything about this movie and one of
the big reasons we could even make
videos here at new rockstars is our
sponsor loot crate loot crate is a
monthly subscription box service that
hooks you up with all sorts of cool gear
from all the nerdy stuff we like to talk
about at this channel including Star
Wars you could sign up right now by
going to Luke rate comm slash rockstars
each month has a theme and this month's
theme is speed which I just got the box
right here and I think we should open it
shall we
well honestly it is less than 20 bucks a
month and if you use our promo code
Rockstar as you get 10% off and we at
new rock stars are doing a bonus
giveaway well you can win the box that I
just opened right here all you got to do
is go to loot crate comm slash rock
stars sign up and then tweet at us that
you signed up and what you're most
excited about for rogue one okay that's
it if you like this video please hit
like and make sure to subscribe to new
rock stars and share this video spread
the good word of NR as we like to say
also shout out to our patreon
contributors Kelly hopper Kenny habul
get to the choppa is a fun thing to say
I just kind of really wanted to say that
but thank you we can't make these videos
without you our beautiful patreon people
you guys are making all these videos
possible you can follow me on twitter at
kyle or buck with any questions about
this stuff or questions about my sanity
or you can follow new rock stars on
twitter at new rockstars to keep up with
us and when our videos are coming out
okay that's it I'm gonna go hit the gym
I'm gonna do I'm gonna work out with
with weights I'm gonna go lift weights
to get muscular more so than I already
am so definitely gonna go do that and
not gonna go play xbox with 10 hours
[Music]